[Musique]
il y va de la vie
si tous quand est astucieux
johnny s'explique sur le plus sérieux et
a joué et vie de famille
bonjour les amis thomas walser bonjour
tout encore dont je vois que tu es de
lola oui j'ai oublié d'arroser la fleur
de mon chapeau à peu la trompait
l'effectif va pas aller j'ai préparé
aujourd'hui une petite expérience ça va
t'amuser piquant bull tu vas voir ça tu
vas voir les plus regardées vous prenez
une allumette
voici une allumette normal bon très bien
alors vous la casser en deux seulement
fait attention que les deux morceaux ne
se sépare pas totalement
il faut qu'ils restent attachés comme
ceci et puis vous les mettez enlevé
comme cela voyez-vous h connaissent
alors mais il faut pas que ça que les
deux morceaux se détachent
alors je le mets la connaît celle là je
la connais cela sur la bouteille
attention jouer quand j'étais oisillons
ah bon oui c'était bien
regarde comme c'est difficile ça bon
alors maintenant vous prenez par exemple
un petit bouton de chemise vous ce
pourrait être une petite pièce de
monnaie c'est plus facile avec un petit
bouton de chemise
vous le voyez les tout petits voilà le
voilà alors je le mets ta boutons de
couleurs ça oui je le mets sur la lui
mais tu vois là et maintenant regardez
bien parce que il va room non avec
quelques gouttes d'eau que je place sur
la partie de l'allumette qui est encore
retenu en principe ça doit s'écarter ça
va marcher regarder réessayer jeu mais
quelques gouttes d'eau et vous c'est
formidable
regardez bien et voilà vous avez vu
c'est inouï
et ce qui s'est passé là le bouton est
tombé dans la bouteille
c'est malin oui mais alors pour le
récupérer parce que lorsque vous mettez
de l'eau ici l'allumette ces cartes
comme ça vous l'avez bien vu regardez
maintenant elle est tout écarter et le
bouton lui est tombé dans la bouteille
moi j'ai quand même fort à cet
extraordinaire
quand même fort c'est quand même
formidable d'abord un petit tout ne soit
pas ça c'est ça c'est dommage que c'est
dommage il était en train de lire la
carte postale de belpech à paris j'avais
pour le mot à mot ah bah oui maintenant
le violent qu'on va jouer au moteur vers
l'on joué route la mort au montana mots
d'amour tu peux t'asseoir je suis assis
bon mot-à-mot des cartons des dessins
qui représentent des syllabes des
syllabes ou morceaux de mots est bon on
reconstitue des mots tous ensemble on y
va et révérend la vue du panneau et
voila j'aimerais qui sans ça ce fait
difficile aujourd'hui
certainement il ça va être difficile
pour eux oui alors je prends cinq
cartons et cinq ans comme d'habitude les
3 4 et 5
voilà alors voilà ce premier carton 1 4x
qu'est ce que c'est ça alors ça
qu'est-ce que ça c'est ce que je me
demande tu vois tu devrais le savoir eh
ben oui là c'est en tout cas
abbas que c'est assez de buts dans un
but de football voilà lilly 1 but et ça
toujours le nez au vent mais ça c'est
une tante rang et sa pagaie des rames
cd-rom une rame une rame et ça ça c'est
un des des indes et alors qu'est ce
qu'on peut vivre et on va te le dis oui
moi toujours moi mes idées avant à 5
heures oui il est assez malin hein il
arrive à nous faire rire
attend il me semble donc oui dix mois on
prononce
bus ou but bas en prenant ce but
but we but alors moi je peux faire du
paon le d1
oui le but le but will attentes
eh ben ça fait mal abou moussa débutante
ils souffrent pense à ça c'est super
c'est fort
celui là il est sensationnel trois
syllabes d'assoli son brave autour des
îles et fort ah oui les mains et puis
c'est moi qui suis une débutante besoin
je n'arrive jamais à trouver mais qui va
arriver mais je suis sûr que je suis
encore en train de chercher un pascal s
ils restent tous et où sam
il faut encore tirer qu'une trame ou au
non je dirais quelques cas ça va le loup
où le loup le loup et sa gare une gare
enseignait à noyon passag et moi aussi
j'en ai un art est j'ai trouvé quelque
chose
qu'est ce que tu as trouvé je crois
qu'il est formidable choisi en trois
syllabes oui loup le loup le loup gare
loups garous ou non là où le loup garou
et trois syllabes aussi comme comme tout
cas encore alors on y est on est comme
qui dirait que les coûts et ça c'est
fort écolo c'est une ex-aequo 1 ex-aequo
alors là je ne suis absolument pas
falloudja fabrice oui louga gains roues
ah bon ah ben oui y'a pas dit que ce
alors que nick sera non gelée ou yannick
jean loup garou bien c'est bien écrit
comme tient bon alors comment on fait
parce qu'on est ex-aequo avec tout quand
les deux suites
oui tous les deux pour tir et violé des
seringues chose que vous ayez perdu
wimbledon si gentil eh bien on va
laisser à bell le choix le bal en
espagne de serrer les coudes belle voilà
l'un ça me tue le monde montre avec ta
main
attends je l'apprends bouge pas voilà
alors tiens ou bien lui faire plaisir à
bell qu'est ce que vous voulez mais oui
mais oui c'est vrai alors c'est une
lettre qui vient de stéphane arthaud qui
habite toulon un soir stéphane lachance
alors mes enfants là je vous laisse
regarder où cette merveille voilà la
merveille regardez minutes la bête au
niveau de l'assise en cours avec ont
tenté pour 6 ans 6 ans thébaux ébahis
promet en artiste déjà très contente
d'avoir tiré du dessin de stéphane soit
tu as bien fait il révèle bien joué
bravo il recevra un disque des caps m
et voilà et ben matra fabrice ça va être
à nous nous allons alors un peu de
courage armée toit de quoi
oui c'est difficile à ton tableau comme
d'habitude oui tu as ton marqueur le
voilà deux voilà bon alors c'est un mot
en off net cette semaine à 9
c'est beaucoup ça neuf lettres ah oui
oui on commence par et bien tu commence
par un c à reims et voilà alors les
petits traits la salle à six est salée
pour les lettres qui manquent pas sur la
dernière le 1e voilà
et crois moi tu vas te régaler et elle a
bon c'est sûr j'aurais légal et ça c'est
un dessert 1 et c'est très beau qu'un
dessert jacob s'en sert pour les deux
c'est un désir se sucrer bien entendu
ainsi et très sucré grèce ukraine à lyon
atteint à temps est ce que est ce que
c'était ses pains fruits quand même
ah non c'est pas ça gratouille sa
sereine non c'est pas un gâteau c'est
pascal buteau une une friandise tous
âges mais on s'en sert aussi pour le
dessert mais demain nous tous une autre
le friant et la la la la troisième les
ouïes 1 1 r ah oui d'accord frère tu vas
tu veux ça devient atteint
est ce que ça ne peut pas être un bon
aussi et oui et oui une friandise un
bonbon alors je vois déjà l'horreur que
tu es nous adressons à crème aussi la
faute d'orthographe y encore fait non
c'est pas possible j'ai pas pu faire de
fautes d'orthographe n'était pas
possible
il s'agit du caramel le caramel alors
caramel j'aimerais bien savoir comment
tu peux mettre un e à la fin de caramel
est passé à ces crises ra ra me2 et le
ramène pauvre pouces moussu encore fait
une faute d'orthographe
enfin ça t'étonne regarde je ne pourrai
jamais y arriver jamais voilà comme on
avait tout simplement ramène tout
simplement
bah oui moi j'ai écris car aller il ya
bien des avions qui s'appelle des
caravelles à l'âge et bien donné nous
avons sur le rapport entre le caramel et
l'écart a même et non à boivin caramel
une car un jour d'accord tu as raison
mais ça m'est égal d'ailleurs mal et
caramel fut pas intérêt à manger parce
que à cause de mes pauvres petites de
presse ansa très très mauvais eh bien
allons voir belle tout de suite ils me
l'on est bas alors voilà ce qu'est ce
qu'un jury avec moi là c'est pas si la
musique du dessin
[Musique]
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
dimanche j'étais préparé ma petite
devinette habituel oui très bien je suis
prêt à lancer et bien aujourd'hui je
crois que c'est assez facile de toute
façon je trouve que tu es très musiciens
que tu trouve facilement
oui m'enfin autour d'elle même bon je te
fais écouter
oui j'appuie sur mon petit bouton sur ma
petite boîte
vas-y
[Musique]
et qui m'arrive
non
[Applaudissements]
c
oui
[Musique]
eh bien j'ai bien oui
c'est un énorme succès ce c'est de
l'harmonica parts et de l'harmonica et
je sais tu as est un film qui est déjà
ancien je pense que vous ne le
connaissez pas parce que vous êtes trop
jeune mais ça a été un film qui avait
énormément de succès et cette musique là
tout le monde l'aimé beaucoup et c'est
donc qu'elle était arrêtée à interpréter
à l'harmonica
monsieur qui s'appelle l'art et adler je
crois que c'est le nom du musicien
voilà un d'accord je crois au tu veux
qu'on l'écouté encore un petit peu
[Musique]
moi j'aurais moi j'ai signé ma vie je
vois et un harmonica dans la main oui
oui oui tu seras jouer alors c'est je ne
sais pas vraiment joué mais en soufflant
dedans on arrive tout de même à faire
les petites choses extraordinaires at on
essayé aller chercher quelque chose
[Musique]
ce sport tout à fait ça m'en font coller
à foix
ok plus complet voilà tu très bien c'est
bien tu sais je savais pas lequel
choisir d'harmonica je commence à en
avoir un tout petit vous avez créé où on
en a un plus grand et puis puis on
choisit la taille qu'on préfère après
oui celui là c'est un bon pour débuter
toyas oui absolument
on chante les quatre amis c'est déjà mon
copain et demi et quatre ans qui serait
que la vie majed est désisté et g shock
ses défenseurs les comme juni pas de
mine war il faudra faire attention les
quatre femmes n'y sont pas cotées sont
réunis des caps à me sens heureux paris
c'est ma vie
[Musique]
bon
mais ça n'est pas joué
aujourd'hui il veut voir devenir amis
c'est vouloir devenir un ami
[Musique]